Alright guys, let's talk about the 80-20 rule with ranking.
If any of you are familiar with the 80-20 rule, I'm gonna mess this up, but basically
20% of your actions make up 80% of your results, okay?
That's essentially what it means.
And so what I'm gonna talk about in this video is those couple of things with ranking that
make all the difference in the world, that make up 80% of your results.
Because with SEO, there's a lot of little nuts and bolts, there's a lot of little things
that you can do, there's a lot of little things that supposedly help.
But there are three, three core things that make up the majority of that ranking.
And this is coming from years and years of experience, talking to SEO experts, studying
SEO, taking countless courses.
There are three things that really, really, really matter.
I'm gonna cover them briefly in here, we're gonna go more into them in future videos,
okay?
I want to remind you, this is an art, not an exact science, okay?
So this is one of those like soft things, it's not like a hard, okay, do this and this
happens, it's, okay, we're trying to figure this out, Google's doing updates, Google's
playing this ridiculous game, but we know that there are three things that matter more
than anything.
So the three things are as follows.
Number one is the age of the website or the age of the domain.
Number two is the backlinks, I'm gonna explain it.
And number three is content.
That's it!
If you can nail those three things, you can understand those three things and you do your
homework correctly on choosing your city and niche, you will have websites where you can
do most everything else wrong and you will rank, okay?
So let's talk about each of them really quick.
Age of domain, very simple.
How old is your domain?
How old, how long has it been online?
And here's what you need to remember.
The older the domain, the better, okay?
The older the domain, the better, because Google's looking at it and in their eyes,
they think, well, if a website has been around for 30 years, pretty good chance that it's
legit because who keeps a website around 30 years, whereas me and you, we come online
yesterday or last week or last month or last year, we could be fly by the night.
So age of domain is something that you can't fake, it's something that you can't really,
well, you can't fake it.
There are some strategies to buying seasoned domains and old domains.
I don't mess with that because again, we're not talking about national rankings, we're
talking about these super competitive niches.
If we do, this is why I stressed so hard on making sure the city and the niche were on
point in the very, in part one of the training, okay?
In the very, very, very first module, that's why we talked about this and looking for layers
because if we do that correctly, then these things aren't as important.
But age of domain, just understand it's a factor and when you're doing your homework
on cities, if you are going up against a website that looks like garbage and you're like, why
are they ranking, it could be that that website's like 40 years old or 30 years old, whatever
the internet started.
And I've come across those, those are hard to beat.
We cannot fake that part, so we have to do the other two correctly.
We have to win at the other two, okay?
Next thing is backlinks and I'm just giving a brief overview here.
Backlinks, I'm gonna explain backlinks and first of all, if you don't know, backlinks
are when you're reading an article, right, or a blog and it's like, yeah, we talked about
this in our other post that you can see here and here is underlined, you can click on it,
it takes you to another article, that's a backlink, okay?
Within backlinks, there are two different types, there's a do follow and a no follow,
I'm gonna be covering that in a future module and lesson, but there's a no follow and a
do follow, do follow help, no follow, technically don't, but enough of that.
Backlinks are really simple, understanding backlinks goes like this.
You know back in high school or maybe you're one of the few in our program that is in high
school and shout out to you guys, but in high school, you know, who you hang out with, everyone
judges you on that, right?
And I'm gonna give you an example, if you are somebody that hangs out with the cowboys
or the cowgirls, even if you're not a cowboy, you are dubbed as a cowboy.
If your friend group is the group that goes and gets high on the weekend or whatever,
gets stoned on Wednesday night, even if you're not smoking weed, guess what?
You're one of the pot smokers or the skateboarders or the jocks, right?
Whoever you hang out with is who people think you are, even if you're not and it's the same
thing online.
Whoever you are linked to is who Google thinks you are.
So if the game is really simple, how do we link ourselves to people or not in this case
of websites of higher status than us, right?
Status status.
If we can link ourselves to, in a perfect world, if we could get a link from Forbes
and Entrepreneur and you know, the New York Times, even though we're this brand new kid
on the block, dude, Google's gonna go, that guy's with the, think about it, right?
If you had three billionaire friends and you guys were just out slumming the town, even
if you had zero dollars in your bank account, people are gonna go, dude, who's that guy?
Who's that girl?
She's in this group, she must be special.
That's how Google looks at it.
So we're gonna get into this, so don't overthink this, but backlinks are important.
They're kind of that like steroid, if you will.
So it's something that gives us that extra boost and there's strategies to getting those
backlinks.
You gotta understand that it's about getting linked to people that Google views as trustworthy
and of high status, okay?
And number three is content and that's the one that we're gonna focus the most on because
of a couple of reasons.
Number one, most business owners are not willing to write content and I'm actually talking
about the words that go on the page, okay?
Most business owners, when they think of writing content, they write a paragraph that's 25
words, maybe a little review at the bottom from one of their customers and boom, they're
done.
But guess what?
Think about it like this, Google does not have eyeballs.
Google has algorithms that crawl our websites.
They can't see what's on your website.
They can only read.
So how is Google, if you don't have anything besides 20 or 25 words of content on your
website, how is Google going to know what your website is about?
How is Google going to know about concrete contractors or that you talk about concrete
contractors if you don't have any content talking about concrete contractors?
Or concrete companies, right?
Or the cost of concrete, or concrete St. George, Utah, or concrete near me.
Yet, these business owners don't understand this.
They don't put any content on their website because content is hard.
Content takes work.
Content takes thinking and thought and getting down and doing it and editing it and putting
it on the site.
It's hard.
So we're gonna do it.
We're gonna do it.
We're gonna master it.
We're gonna dominate it.
We are going to win, mark my words and listen to me carefully, we are going to win this
SEO game with content.
We can't do a whole lot about age.
We can't.
But we can do something about backlinks and we certainly can do something about content.
So when we get to the content module and you're like, oh my gosh, he's asking me to do so
much, you're welcome.
Because that is the very thing that's going to make the difference because no one's willing
to do it and it's very, very, very important.
Every word that we put on the page matters.
Every word matters because it's exactly what Google is going to look at.
And when I say look at, I mean analyze because they don't have eyes.
These are algorithms that crawl.
They read the text.
They don't look at the pictures.
They don't look at the website.
So content is super, super important.
So guys, I just wanted you to have a quick overview of these different pieces of SEO.
And the three things that matter again are the age of the domain, your backlinks and
your content.
Now, as we get going, we're gonna be talking about on-page SEO and off-page SEO and within
that there's multiple facets and we're gonna be talking about image optimization and all
these things.
But I want you to stay focused on age of domain, which you can't really control, but you need
to consider.
You need to be focused on backlinks and content.
If you can master content and you can get good at content and creating keyword lists
and writing content, and guys, it doesn't have to be perfect.
We're gonna get into that.
But if you can focus on those things, this is the 80-20 rule.
If you can focus and master those three things, you will rank in the majority of these cities
and niches if you have done module one, looking for layups correctly.
All right, guys, let's go build our website.